jigsaw your routines and jigsaw have led
to many breakups four thousand breakup
17 canceled engagements and nine
divorces you're actually counting these
because you ordered on social media that
people see your act in jigsaw and it
makes them want to break up why what is
it about the act it's it's not a break
up show I've always had jigsaw is just a
love letter to single people like I
think as a society we pressure people to
get into relationships and I think
there's a certain level of arrogance to
people in relationships that they have
on social media of like me and this one
going for coffee like that's I feel like
they're rubbing it in the faces of the
people that aren't in relationships when
deep down they're equally unhappy and I
don't like the smugness of it and I'm
the smartest person I know so while I
smoke them and now they're getting
divorced okay so you're basically saying
that you don't think they're as happy as
they say they are is that right I think
some people absolutely are truly in love
and I do I can't break those
relationships and open I would never
want to yeah all I'm doing is asking you
the uncomfortable questions that you
don't have the courage to ask yourself
and I bet my my own money on it that you
won't last really and I'm I'm not proud
of this and you started out when the
special aired I think you how many
people when you tape the special how
many people had broken up at that point
who had just seen your stage act yeah it
was 72 and then in five days has gone up
to 4,000 and or it's so good so this is
like I'm on Instagram every day just
going through to fill it because you've
created almost like a virus and you've
put it out there and it's destroying the
bonds that hold people together I would
say it's more like a medicine like it's
just it's it's curing the bad
relationships by stopping them from
existing
you know I've thought about this before
I read an article once that said at the
at the BMW plant or Mercedes plant
there's a mission there's a giant claw
that takes like every 30th car on the
assembly line off the line and lifts it
up and shakes it really hard and if one
bolt falls out they know we're not
making these cars right and it sounds
like that's what your your show is doing
is it's taking relationships it's
shaking them really hard if the
relationship can survive you're special
it's a good relation it's a good
relationship and also if it fails like
there are 7.5 billion people on the
planet it's not like we're not spoiled
for choice every day yeah yes I think it
was never meant to break couples up
there was an accidental byproduct but I
would be absolutely lying if I didn't
say I loved every second okay well you
may be the most evil person I've met
recently Daniels gonna be performing his
latest show now in New York City at the
Soho Playhouse from February 6 through
the 24th and dark and jigsaw as I
mentioned are available now on Netflix
people in relationships watch at your
own risk Daniel sloths thanks so much
for being here
[Applause]
you